well this is extraordinary because we
now know that the prime minister has
misled the house of commons we know he's
lied repeatedly
we're in a situation where the
metropolitan police are looking at
events over multi-periods multi-parties
perhaps as many as four that the prime
minister had been at people are outraged
by
a prime minister that simply won't
accept responsibility there has to be
dignity in public life i i followed the
previous prime minister theresa may
yesterday and had many disagreements
with teresa but i respected her for her
integrity her honesty and the
recognition of the office that she held
this is a prime minister that's demeaned
the office and he should have been gone
by now
well you must hold the metropolitan
police in the say same high level as you
do the former prime minister so why not
just let them get on with their work
because at the end of the day we now
have enough evidence we know
what we're doing so far is the sugary
report i mean it's not as we would like
we want to see the fuel report it's
important that we get that but the
sugary report points out there were
failures of leadership the events took
place there were events across 12 dates
as many as 16 parties that took place
the prime minister has admitted that
being at these events and the public
rightly are outraged so many people that
sacrificed so much
that simply can't accept that the prime
minister had this culture of partying
where they were not able to grieve for
their dying relatives he was
inadvertently at these parties these
events it just happened to have the fact
that parties were taking place in the
downing street flat but you know other
things have come out over the course of
the last few days kay the fact that we
know that security briefings
highly sensitive security briefings have
been left lying around the downing
street flat left lying around checkers
the fact that people could come and go
it's no it's it's been reported and that
we now know that he doesn't take these
sensitive papers in his red box into his
accommodation this is a prime minister
doesn't well no we now know that this
prime minister
doesn't recognize the gravity
of his actions the significance of his
actions this man is a threat to national
security but what we do know is that the
government
well the government's been found guilty
of court in court of illegal covert
contracts we know that this man
illegally shut down
well but it's about the behavior of a
prime minister that is cavalier in his
approach that treats downing street in
government as a personal play thing he
thinks he can get away with it and it's
important that conservative mps use
their power to say enough is enough that
this man should felt that it's important
enough for at least 12 events to be
looked at by the police and she's given
them a wealth of evidence 500 pieces of
paper 300 photographs as i said dominick
robb who takes 300 photographs at work
events i don't know but obviously
somebody does um why not just wait for
that because the man is a distraction he
was supposed to have a conversation
yesterday with president putin but what
he's doing is he's spending time in
meetings in downing street trying to get
tory mps from coming back from the cliff
edge of putting in motions of no
confidence in them we face a mountain of
challenges the situation with ukraine
and russia the cost of living crisis and
all that we're talking about is a prime
minister that simply cannot behave
cannot show that he has what it takes to
give leadership at a time of crisis
whether it's the pandemic whether it's a
cost of living crisis whether it's a
security situation he needs to recognize
he is up to them not you well they will
in the end recognize that his time will
be up this prime minister will not go
into the next election and i think
people want to see change and i suppose
as an snp mp as the snp leader at
westminster i'm lucky that we have a
choice in scotland we will be having an
independence referendum we can find a
way from the sleaze and corruption that
we see at westminster but this is a man
that's tainted our democracy
independence referendums are for another
day we're not talking about those today
we're talking about what happened in the
house yesterday you actually left rather
than be thrown out yeah i did i
certainly didn't want to cause a problem
for the speaker but i must say i have a
responsibility to stand up and speak
truth to power i did have a opposition
day a couple of months ago where it was
agreed in the context of that i could i
could lay out the charge sheet against
the prime minister about someone that
has told that someone that has broken
the ministerial code so there's
precedent for me doing what i did and i
think my constituents
and my colleagues would expect me to
stand up and say this man has behaved in
a way which is yeah but you're not
saying you know the rules better than
the speaker are you of course and so the
speaker asked you to retract it and you
chose not to do that what do you say to
people who say you you detracted from
from events of the day by a bit of
things no because what i'm doing is i'm
shining a light on the behavior of the
prime minister that should have resigned
on the basis that he's misled the house
of commons he came to the house of
commons on the 8th of december and said
that no parties had taken place he knew
that he'd been at parties he told labour
mp catherine west that no event had
taken place
well he has now subsequently admitted
that he was at these parties
events that he didn't know they were
parties i think that the world knows
that there were parties if there was
drink being taken if it looks like a
duck if it quacks like a duck it's a
duck these were parties we know it the
prime minister knows it and he needs to
accept responsibility and we can wait
until the police tell us whether it's a
duck or not
i think we all in the meantime what
happens to you now because you left the
chamber are you lied back in
yes i was back in the chamber last night
i've
met with the speaker i have every regard
for the speaker and the role that he has
to do
and of course he has to discharge his
obligations as speaker in the house i
have an obligation to make sure that i'm
standing up for my constituents and
standing up for those that have made
enormous sacrifices and yes it is the
case that i need to stand by the remarks
that i made that this prime minister
seems to be a stranger to the truth and
a prime minister that has misled the
house of commons is that is that the end
of the matter or do you well that's up
to i i i trust you apologize to the
prime minister i i don't have anything
to apologize to it's the prime minister
that needs to accept his
responsibilities and resign i'll do my
job of making sure that i'm holding this
prime minister to account i mean it's
not waving the mace above your head as
michael hesseltein has done previously
but nevertheless you know you did leave
before you were thrown out so there must
be some repercussions for that well look
that's that is up for others but i think
the public will judge and i know that
from the public reaction that we've had
over the last 24 hours that people have
said thank goodness
someone has been able to stand up in the
house of commons and tell it as it is
i have that duty in that obligation
i want to be in the house of commons
doing my job
that's what i've been sent to do but the
house of commons has to come into the
21st century and when you've got a prime
minister that is behaving as he has done
a prime minister that's been
investigated by the police
i do have that responsibility to stand
up to shine a light on his behavior do
you regret leaving the house of commons
yesterday i no i i did that because un
under the circumstances that was the
right thing to do um but
at the end of the day i've been sent to
westminster to stand up for our
constituents to lead the snp at
westminster i have to call out the prime
minister for the charlatan that he is
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us